IS THE RECONCILIATION BILL
WHITTLED DOWN TO 2 THELITIS.
WE -- TRILLION DOLLARS.
WE ARE SUPPOSED TO BOD
E TH.
DOES THIS BILL NEED TO DIE?
ARE WE IN BIG TROUBLE?
>> WELL, SAVE AMERICA AND KILL
THE BILL IS MY MOTTO.
2 TRILLION DOLLARS IS
UNIMPRESSIVE.
THERE ARE ACCOUNTING GIMMICKS IN
THERE.
CHILD ALLOWANCES FOR ONE YEAR
BUT IT'S A TRILLION DOLLARS OVER
10 YEARS.
THEY WILL DO EVERYTHING TO
CONTINUE IT FOR 10 YEARS.
THERE ARE ONLY 2 OBSTACLES TO
THIS CRAZY 5 TRILLION DOLLARS
PLUS TAXING AND SPENDING BILL.
ONE IS JOE MANCHIN AGAINST THE
SPENDING AND THE OTHER IS
KRYSTEN SINEMA.
THEY ARE WASHINGTON'S MOST
IMPORTANT POWER COUPLE OF THE
MOMENT.
THEY CAN STOP THIS BILL.
THESE ATTACKS ON FOSSIL FUEL AND
OIL AND GAS AND COAL DECIMATED
US.
THE BIDEN WAS AASLEEP ON THE
SWITCH ON THE SUPPLY CHAIN
SHORTAGES -- AND THE
CONTAINERSHIP BACK UP IN L.A.
LONG BEACH.
THE LONG SHORE MAN DIDN'T WANT
GO TO 24/7.
WITH ALL OF THE TALK ABOUT
INFRASTRUCTURE, THERE IS NOTHING
IN THERE THAT WOULD GET UP-STATE
ON MACHINERY AND AUTOMATION IN
THESE PORTS.
THAT'S ALSO BECAUSE IT IS LONG
SHORE MEN OPPOSE IT.
CONSUMERS DON'T WANT TO WAIT.
THEY HATE SHORTAGES.
THEY WANT PROSPERITY AND
GOVERNMENT'S CENTRAL PLANNING IS
NOT THE ANSWER.
>> Laura: ABOUT THE FACT THAT WE
WERE ABLE TO RAMP UP
MANUFACTURING IN THE UNITED
STATES IN THE 1930s AND '40s TO
WIN THE WAR.
WE COULD DO THAT BUT WE CAN'T
GET CARGO UNLOADED FROM SOME
SHIPS?
>> IT'S UNBELIEVABLE.
>> Laura: IT'S A JOKE.
>> I LIKED YOUR OPENING.
YOU ARE RIGHT.
THE ONLY THING THE OPENING
SHOULD HAVE ADDED WHEN YOU PUT
THE INDIVIDUALS RUNNING THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION.
IT LOOKED LIKE THE JUNIOR
VARSITY.
IT MIGHT HAVE BEEN THE FRESHMAN
TEAM.
>> Laura: IT'S AMATEUR HOUR.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> Laura: ALL RIGHT.
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> Laura: LARRY, HOLD ON.
THE STRIKING FIGURE THAT SPELLS
OUT WHAT BIDEN HAS DONE.
THE GDP GROWTH ESTIMATE IS .5%.
IT WAS 6% JUST 2 MONTHS AGO.
UNDER TRUMP OUR GROWTH WOULD BE
FLYING HOW NOW BECAUSE HE WOULD
NOT HAVE DONE THE ENERGY STUFF
AND BORROWING.
WHAT IS CALLING THAT .5%?
>> THERE WERE NO CARS TO BUY.
CONSUMER SPENDING LOOKS WEAK.
IT'S NOT BUT THERE ARE NO CARS
TO BUY BECAUSE OF THESE
CONTAINER BACKUPS.
THEY HAD SEMI-CONDUCTORS THE
CARS NEED.
AND THE INFLATION BULGE.
WHETHER IT'S TEMPORARY OR
PERMANENT DOESN'T MATTER.
IT EXITS TODAY.
WE ARE MAKING IT WORSE BY
CREATING THIS ENVIRONMENT EVER
SCARCITY.
THE "WASHINGTON POST" IS WRITING
ONLY WEALTHY PEOPLE HAVE
PATIENCE.
-- THAT'S VINTAGE JIMMY CARTER.
THAT'S MALAISE TALK.
WHAT IS AT THE ROOT OF THIS IS
VERY BAD GOVERNMENT DECISIONS.
THAT'S WHAT I AM TOUTING MANCHIN
AND SINEMA.
BOTH SHOULD CALL UP DONALD TRUMP
AND ASK TO BECOME REPUBLICANS.
THERE IS NO PLACE IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY FOR SENSIBLE
MODERATES WHICH IS A SHAME.
>> Laura: WE HAVE TO GO.
JOE MANCHIN IS WORKING AGAINST
THE INTEREST OF THE PEOPLE OF
WEST VIRGINIA.
THEY WANT SENSIBLE POLICY.
JOE MANCHIN YOU HAVE TO BE
BETTER THAN THAT.